[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حداثه او التكنولوجيا والتكنيك والعالم
النت والسوشيال ميديا اثرت على الشغله
وبالتالي احنا هنانا لازم ننهض بالفن لانه
الخط اللي يجيك بالحاسبه خط مابي مسحه
فنيه ولا بلمسه فنيه وبالتالي احنا لازم
نطلع القلق الجمالي لهذا الحرف العربي
بكتاباتنا وباليد وباليد
وبضوابطها وقواعدها ونقاطها
[موسيقى]
العاليه هسه عندنا الدوره عن خط الرقعه
يعني هو ابسط انواع الخطوط وممكن يعني
الخطا مبتدئ
من مارسه يعني ممكن يتقني اسهل من بقيه
الخطوط
يعني هو الفتره مالته تعليم مالته تصير
اقل لان الخطوط الباقيات شويه بين صعوبه
فيحتاج الوقت اكثر
[موسيقى]
ليش نتعلم حتى ناكدها وتراثنا وفنا لانه
شعب بلا هويه ولا تراك ولا ثقافه ولا فن
شعب ميت
[موسيقى]